secretary-general prime ministers
presidents excellencies allow me to
start by thanking all of you for the
initiative to discuss financing for the
development in the context of
coronavirus and moreover thank you for
inviting the European Union to be part
of this debate the pandemic hit everyone
not only exposing our level of
preparedness to cope with massive
challenges but also realities of global
development we have to be honest and
admit that before the pandemic hit the
world was set on an unsustainable
economic path rising inequalities a
growing digital divide a man-made
climate crisis the corona virus is not
only shining a light on these trends it
has made some of them even more dramatic
countries all across the world have been
hit hard by the virus the lack of
digital skills and infrastructure is
taking a toll on company students and
families alike the gap between the haves
and have-nots of our world is growing
even bigger if possible the sustainable
development goals are even more crucial
now than at their inception and
coronavirus clearly demonstrates that
sustainable development goals are
equally important for every human being
on earth the goals are not set only for
those undergoing development but for all
with this in mind I presented just
yesterday a recovery plan for Europe
that is deeply inspired by the idea of
competitive sustainability it has the
European Green Deal at its core it
invests in digital transformation it
will also invest in health systems all
of this with one specific aim reducing
inequalities across our Union we will
not just rebuilt but we reshape our
economy to make it more resilient and
sustainable we're putting together the
biggest package worldwide that links
invest
for recovery to the sustainable
development spirit I could not agree
more with secretary-general Guterres
when he says that we must build back
better crisis as we face it might
influence our thinking and actions
pushing us to concentrate only on our
own agenda and only on our own needs but
this is wrong we have to work together
and for each other in these demanding
times Europe is ready to work with those
who need to support the most Team Europe
has already pledged 23 billion euros to
support our partners and facing the
emergency we are we were proud to host
an online pledging conference to raise
95 9.5 billion euros for vaccines and
cures and make them affordable worldwide
but our actions cannot stop here
therefore today I would like to propose
something even more ambitious we need a
global recovery initiative that links
investment and debt relief to the
sustainable development goals Europe is
ready to put on the table expertise and
resources with both traditional and
innovative financing instruments but we
must be clear on what kind of recovery
we aspire to it should be a green
recovery a digital recovery adjust and
resilient recovery the post pandemic
world can be more inclusive and greener
than the one we know it is up to us to
build back better together thank you